oh my gosh this might happen okay plot
twist kind of up my cake
it's a bowl of vegetables i took a big
risk i thought it would pay off
gorgeous it's just six-year-old behavior
yum i'm into this
oh yeah thumbs up is it good oh yum
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okaiest
mom and
last season i secretly hid veggies in my
family's food for an entire week
and it was a huge success so this time
i'm going to try to take it even further
i'm going to secretly feed my family
vegan food for well
i'm going to secretly feed my family
vegan food for an entire week
will this seven day vegan challenge
solve my problems i don't know let's
find out wish me luck
so here's the plan for the week i want
to make every single meal
and snack vegan for the entire family
minus henry
i'm gonna just tell them that i'm trying
new recipes which
i've used that excuse a lot i think so i
don't know how well it's gonna work
we have tried a seven day vegan
challenge before
and i got a lot of good advice saying
that i wasn't prepared enough and that i
bought too many pre-made foods and
that's why my grocery bill was so high
so this time i think i have a better
grasp of
what is vegan and what is not if i make
it through this week and nobody notices
that i'm sneaking vegan foods
i get to treat myself to an entire pint
of my favorite ice cream
so first things first where am i we
moved
basically working from home with all the
kids at home
and only having a pool and concrete
backyard
like drove me to the brink so we sold
our house in l.a
we're living out in the california
desert in a tiny tiny
1 000 square foot home but there is lots
of land and lots of outdoor space
and we're really loving it here and i've
since
discovered my love for crocs i have two
pairs of dope crocs
anyway that's our situation onto the
food vegan
breakfast is actually pretty easy to
make because we usually do a lot of
fruits for most breakfast
i just make toast and i'll do this like
superfood honey
wait is honey vegan
so i googled it and i feel like there's
a lot of
mixed opinions around honey some people
choose to eat it
as vegans and some don't so i just
played it safe and i put it back
in the cupboard instead i'm going to do
some superfood coconut butter
serve it with some sliced banana
yum something that i had recently
discovered before this week
was vegan yogurt it has come such a long
way
in terms of creaminess and flavor that
it's almost
indistinguishable it is so delicious so
i got this
they can read so i'm going to put it in
another bowl and see if anybody notices
you guys want a little yogurt before we
go on our walk
i love yogurt do you want soda okay i'll
get you some
bye don't hover thank you so i was so
excited to see the boys blind taste test
this yogurt and see what they thought
because they are
yogurt connoisseurs that's good
how are you doing wyatt they loved it
they could not tell the difference they
thought it was delicious
and i will keep buying it thumbs up
is that good oh yum so day one was easy
let's take on day two day two was all
about the cheese i've had
very mixed luck with vegan cheese and i
really wanted to do something special
and tasty
i'm making deluxe cheesy back i hope it
substitutes with no issue
and just with the theme of cheese i've
decided i'm going to serve it with a
caprese salad
i found a vegan mozzarella and so it
gave me the idea to make a caprese salad
i got this beautiful big heirloom got
some regular
tomato okay plot twist this mozzarella
is very mushy this cheese turned out to
be
more like a thick cream cheese it's not
like like a regular mozzarella where it
has like
some bounce and some stretch to it
it does taste good though the flavor was
there so i didn't even mind the
difference in texture
the boys on the other hand you don't
like that cheese
tomatoes i like what's wrong with the
cheese i don't like the tomatoes because
there's green stuff on
it's basil friend then just take the
basil off
okay really good
[Music]
that's really good the noodles are good
the sauce is fine
everybody loved the mac and cheese they
ate it they loved the meal
why it did notice it doesn't taste like
cheese
but he still ate it it made me a little
nervous that they might have noticed
that
it was a vegan meal so i figured
day three i'd have to step it up a
little bit more we're getting a late
start to dinner
but i have my potato peeler right here
while we make coconut curry so when we
were living in los angeles
this thai restaurant that was by our
house had this amazing
yellow curry with potatoes and carrots
and chicken
so i use that as inspiration for my day
three meal
at the core i am a clean out the fridge
cook
i am not a recipe person i look at
what's in my fridge
i look at what's about to go bad and i
figure out what to make with it
and that was my biggest mistake on day
three i had kale that was on its last
legs i had to use it
and i wanted to see if they still
enjoyed mushrooms
and i think it was just too much and yes
those are crops
what are your thoughts
what do you see i see mushrooms my
favorite
you like mushrooms yeah
it's good what do you think ryan
[Music]
wyatt what's your favorite part
[Music]
you'll notice that wyatt doesn't talk
much in this video i think it's
primarily because his sassiness has
evolved to the next level where he
refuses to acknowledge me sometimes
what do you think it's like thai thai
flavor
is it like the restaurant yeah henry
is full-blown toddler now so he was
painfully trying to get something off
the table
any different
the curry was underwhelming it was
a little too vegetable forward i'd say i
really think that after today
they're on to me so day four my mission
was to throw them
off it's burger day these look great
they cook up just like regular burgers
i made a salad with tomato butter
lettuce cucumber usually i would top it
with some
cheese but we're not gonna miss it and
then i have all the fixings
for some epic burgers and then i did get
some
veganese i've heard great things about
veganism
i've heard that it actually tastes
better than regular mayonnaise
so i figured what better way to try it
than on a burger
we're gonna put it to the test it looks
like you use like
vegan vegan burgers yeah beyond burgers
do you like them though yeah they're
yummy
it's fantastic
[Music]
honey just give it a taste it's not
mayo it's a cream sauce try it
are you finished oh my goodness
thumbs up they loved the burgers
end of day four i am feeling
very confident in my sneaky skills i
feel like i've thrown them off
completely and they don't suspect a
thing
so of course i blow it on day five
dinner time
tonight for dinner i am going all out
i'm going to make an epic stir fry
the one thing i'm going to try to
incorporate is tofu
i like tofu i eat tofu all the time i
serve it to my family
and i know that they don't like it so
why i decided to
bring out the tofu for this week in
particular is beyond me
i should have known i have this gorgeous
head of cauliflower
i'm gonna roast this separately some of
the best vegan food that i've ever had
is asian inspired with asian seasonings
and flavors
ponzu sauce so good on a stir fry
i thought would go over really well and
maybe change their mind about tofu
i was wrong what do you think
[Music]
there was a very adverse reaction to my
stir-fry
you'd rather have fun yeah i would
rather
sorry this is what henry thought even
henry didn't like
it tough customer it's a bowl of
vegetables
and rice everybody hates it it's fine
it's not great
day five big fail 100 my fault but i
had two more days to really
blow it out of the water and do a good
job so day six i decided to make
buffalo chicken burgers because the beef
fooled them pretty well so i wanted to
see how
fake chicken did can't go wrong with a
little fruit on the side
this looks good how does lunch look
good it's really good wait did you see i
gave you a small avocado piece just to
try
will you eat it yes amazing
what do you think it's really good oh
gosh there's a big mess on the table
that's good the bun certainly helps this
is very good
those chicken patties were fantastic and
crispy
and juicy and so good down to the flavor
and texture if you hadn't told me they
were vegan i probably
wouldn't have noticed yay finally
something quiet like
it seems like i have three happy
customers i think
they ate that entire meal truly
believing that it was chicken
day six was a big win back on track so
day seven it was time to finish strong
day seven big finish here's what i
decided to do
i wanted to combine a classic meal with
a wild card ingredient so i'm gonna make
some pasta sauce some bolognese and
spaghetti obviously spaghetti what else
do they make up my game
i've gotten these meatless browns
and i'm gonna put these in my sauce and
they're gonna be delicious
and as an appetizer you can grab cakes
i am allergic to shellfish and
it was an adult onset allergy so i
didn't become allergic to shellfish
until after i'd already had wyatt i am
so excited for these if these taste
anything like crab cakes i'm gonna freak
out the secret to my tomato sauce i use
san marzano tomatoes
and i like to get the whole peeled ones
and i squish them with my hands
so satisfying got some salt and then
i'll add a
healthy amount of oregano then
lightly dried basil but the great thing
about san marzano tomatoes
is they're less acidic so they make the
sauce
really sweet you don't have to add any
sugar or anything and
this might happen so i'm going to
bring this sauce to a boil reduce the
heat to a simmer and
just do it forever set it and forget it
you want to simmer as long as you can
releases all the flavor makes a
delicious sauce i have my vegan crab
cakes cooking
appetizer is served
[Music]
not quite but still good just
it's not very crabby
you have to buy this again this would be
the best one
jackson was crab cake he fell in love i
think maybe because
he was so young when i became allergic
to shellfish
he doesn't really know what it tastes
like or remember what it tastes like
so this is the first time he's really
had anything close
to a crab cake
you don't like it wyatt did not like the
crab cakes
which didn't surprise me and all it
meant was there were more for jackson to
enjoy
oh yeah this looks fantastic is that
good
yeah it is good
i'm missing a little parmesan oh they
love my pasta
i make good pasta i made it through the
week
i really felt like the boys didn't
suspect anything at all
so all that was left was to tell them do
you remember the
food we've had the past week did you
know that it was all vegan
yeah and they knew the whole time
so i tried to be a sneaky mom for the
week and my sons are so kind
they humored me but i thought i was the
sneaky one in the family but they're the
real sneaks of this video
so the one thing that i did take away
from this week was i found a lot of
meals that they really enjoy
and that was really exciting because i
want to continue to incorporate more
plant-based
meals into our diet so i know i said
that if i made it through the week and
tricked the boys
i got to reward myself with a pint of
ice cream now i didn't trick them
but i did already buy the ice cream and
i'm an adult and i can do whatever i
want
so that's it for now i'm hannah and if
you don't already make sure you follow
me on instagram and please message me
and let me know
how you think i did with this challenge
was i sneaky was i not am i a mean mom
please let me know and if you'll excuse
me i have some
work to do on this ice cream til next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you